foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers yet
great meat at a secure price and 30
bucks off your order with my code
Knowles kwles go to goodranchors.com use
code Knowles kwles today artificial
intelligence not only paints pictures
not only writes essays and speeches now
ai has written a love song we will get
to the lyrics of that in just a moment
first though
I'm not sure if that introduction was
allowed on YouTube
it was about the topic that we're not
allowed to talk about on YouTube but I
was just reporting the news on a thing
that happened in Russia on that top so I
don't know
in any case if you want to get the full
show with the parts that are not allowed
on YouTube you've got to go to daily
wire plus and Twitter at M knoll's show
and the RSS feed and apple podcast
Spotify and all over the place anyway
tangentially related to the point in my
introduction is a claim made by Hillary
Clinton
Hillary Clinton just weighed in on the
heat wave that we're experiencing and
she said quote hot enough for you thank
a Maga Republican or better yet vote
them out of office
Hillary Clinton you know she's the adult
in charge she's the really serious
person and this very serious person is
saying that summer heat waves
a feature of life for all of history
are the fault of Republicans and not
those Mitt Romney Republicans by the way
not those nice little Republicans who
Swish and help out the Democrats the
Maga Republicans the conservatives
conservatives are responsible for the
weather
I thought the last theory on that was
that the Jews controlled the weather
wasn't that that was the last conspiracy
theory now sorry Jews you're out it's
the Maga Republicans who control the
weather now I don't know when we get our
space lasers when's Hillary going to
start talking about the Maga Republican
space laser I don't know it's just as
crazy a theory though we
we don't control the weather we don't
control the heat it's been hot in July
forever and uh Donald Trump is not
responsible for that at all I mentioned
this story not to point out that Hillary
Clinton is a very silly lady not to
point out that the libs are far crazier
than the conservatives are all of that
obviously we just take that for granted
the thing I want to point out here
is a trick of the libs which is that the
libs are very good at appealing to the
Flesh and conservatives are not as good
at that conservatives are really good at
making logical arguments conservatives
are really good at destroying people
with facts and logic and making all
sorts of intellectual and historical and
philosophical points sure the libs are
really good at appealing to the Flesh
and they do this through all sorts of
decadent temptations that they make
obviously the sexual Revolution
obviously the drugs obviously all those
kinds of things we see but even here
even in this silly Hillary Clinton tweet
she says hey are you feeling hot right
now do you feel uncomfortable are you
sweating yeah that's Republican's fault
does that make any sense no they come up
with some tenuous Preposterous argument
you know well actually because the
Republicans drive cars like we all do
and Republicans use oil like everyone on
earth does that some that because of
that and the oil anger is the sun
monster and the sun monster shines his
Rays even more strongly and the climate
catastrophe warming cooling change
whatever that's that's the but the
argument is secondary what what is
primary is the appeal to the flesh
and so because they can speak in this
fleshy kind of language and appeal to
your your base or appetites and appeal
to your sensation they Forge that
connection such that when completely
unrelated events happen when the water
goes up when the water goes down when
the ice breaks off when there's too much
ice when there's a hurricane when
there's not a hurricane whenever
anything happens in the weather and you
feel it you have that connection in
there it's it's irrational but so much
of politics is based on sentiment you
know a friend and colleague of mine
likes to say facts don't care about your
feelings politics largely cares about
your feelings and the libs get that a
lot better than conservatives do and so
we can all mock Hillary's argument it
will have a lot of currency for a lot of
people now speaking of
failed presidential candidates Mitt
Romney is urging Republicans in the 2024
field to drop out of the race so that
the anti-trump forces can rally around
one guy and presumably in this case that
one guy would be Ron DeSantis who's in
the number two position Romney doesn't
even focus on that really he just
focuses on the also Rams the inevitable
also Iran's who are polling at one and
two and three percent right now he says
you've got to get out of the race
and then he speaks directly to donors
and that's who is Wall Street Journal
op-ed is aimed at
donors don't fund a trump plurality as
in 2016.
Republican candidates won't drop out
soon enough here's how to give them a
push despite Trump's apparent
inevitability a Baker's Dozen
Republicans are hoping to become the
party's 2024 nominee for president there
are incentives for no hope candidates to
overstay their prospects that's why you
donors need to defund them okay okay so
what's the argument here
the argument is that if there's a
two-person race and it's Trump versus
the anti-trump guy then the the
anti-trump guy is definitely going to
win he's the real shot the problem is
the polls don't bear that out according
to the polls not only is Trump trouncing
the rest of the field with all of them
in even when it comes down to a
head-to-head with his most formidable
Challenger Trump continues to trance him
we'll get on more of that in just a
second first though I I want to talk
about how you can trounce your appetites
and how you can trounce bad dinners you
can do that with good dinners from good
ranchers right now head on over to
goodranchers.com promo code Knowles you
know I love anything made with top of
the line quality for meat it is good
ranchers simple as that the only thing
that was missing from good ranchers
truly this was my only complaint about
good Ranchers but I did complain about
this to sweet little Elisa
they were missing some pork
and I like well let me tell you
something when you ask for for things
good ranchers delivers good ranchers has
just launched their Prime pork 100
American pork that is Steakhouse quality
this new pork box comes with bone-in and
boneless pork chops sausage smoke brats
and more plus right now you get 30 bucks
off with code Knowles at goodranters.com
on their site you can explore their
All-American cuts of prime pork Prime
Beef and better than organic chicken
options if you've tried their beef and
chicken before then you know how amazing
it is you've got to try the prime pork
at least once they have got genuinely
great products and top-tier customer
service I love it my only thing that I'm
really missing now while I'm traveling
in Hungary other than my wife and
children is my good ranchers when I go
home in a sweet little Elisa three times
a week makes me juicy delicious steak
and one of the last meals I had before I
left was was a good ranches Burger it's
the best it's like the best burger I've
ever had in my life what are you waiting
for go to goodranchers.com code Knowles
30 bucks off any box
goodranchers.com promo code Knowles k w
l e s goodranchors.com American Meat
delivered Romney's op-ed would make a
lot more sense if right now it were
Trump is up over the field but when it's
Trump versus DeSantis DeSantis wins or
when it's Trump versus young kid or when
it's Trump versus Tim Scott or what
whoever but it's not Trump continues to
have a commanding lead even when it's
one on one
this plays into a broader
argument a broader theme that the
establishment GOP has been pushing for
many decades now and the theme is this
that in the primary the base wants to go
out and nominate the most Conservative
candidate but that's actually going to
harm us in the general election
you know in order to win the primary you
might have to lose the general election
isn't that what a tragedy of politics
what we if we really wanted to win the
general election we'd nominate a
moderate Centrist kind of liberal
candidate and that candidate would
appeal to moderate and Centrist voters
and then we'd win in a landslide if only
you damned conservatives would stop
dominating the GOP Primary field that's
the argument we've heard variations on
it for decades
it isn't true it has no basis in history
the last time
basically I'll put a little asterisk
here basically the last time a moderate
so-called Centrist kind of liberal
Republican candidate won the presidency
was was 1956.
and and really the last time this
happened in a challenger kind of way was
1952 and it was Dwight Eisenhower
since then Eisenhower wins in 56 he was
the moderate liberal Republican kind of
candidate who beat out the more
conservative candidate Taft
since then though let's just look at the
record let me just go off the top of my
head we had Richard Nixon in 1960 who
lost
there it was a little bit of a sus race
but
still I'll give it okay he lost but then
he won
Richard Nixon
then one in 1968 and won re-election in
1972.
who is the next nominee Barry Goldwater
conservative
so Nixon conservative
and certainly even if you think Nixon
was a little bit squishy Nixon compared
to his primary opponent Nelson
Rockefeller who was Mr liberal
Republican Nixon was the Conservative
candidate the libs always thought of him
as conservative he was right about Alger
his he was a Hardline anti-communist I I
count Nixon a conservative
Barry Goldwater Conservative candidate
loses after that okay Nixon wins after
the Deep State runs Nixon out Jerry Ford
liberal Republican candidate he loses
after Jerry Ford the nominee is a
Conservative Republican Ronald Reagan
Reagan wins Reagan wins re-election
after Reagan you get a liberal
Republican a moderate kind of candidate
George H.W bush he does win
but this is why I put the asterisk there
he wins as Reagan's third term
in 1992 when George H.W bush had to run
as his own candidate after the memory of
Reagan had faded H.W bush loses 96 we
nominate a moderate Republican Bob Dole
he loses 2000 we nominate a guy who at
least ran as a Conservative Republican
George W bush you might say George W
bush wasn't really conservative sure but
in the race he was running as the
Conservative candidate much more
conservative than his father and much
more conservative than the other
candidates in the race at least that's
how he was running
2004 Bush gets reelected okay so the
conservative wins both times there then
what happens 2008 we nominate the
moderate centers Republican John McCain
he loses 2012 we nominate the moderate
Centrist Republican Mitt Romney he loses
2016 we nominate the crazy far-right
populist awful no-good conservative
Trump he wins 2020
I guess he loses some some say I don't
know you know they changed a lot of
those rules unlike in 1960 where a lot
of people say that Nixon had the the
election stolen from him maybe he did
but at least there if Kennedy stole the
election he stole it within the normal
bounds of politics within the normal
campaign rules in 2020
I add far more of a question mark to
that election because the libs changed
all of the rules in the lead-up to that
election in some cases illegally in some
cases unconstitutionally to give an
advantage to Dems so in any case I'm not
arguing that if you nominate a
conservative it's a sure thing that the
Republicans are going to win the
election far from it it's far from a
sure thing
but I am pointing out
it is a far safer bet to bet on
conservative Republicans as the GOP
nominee than on the moderate squishy
Centrist Republicans those guys pretty
much always lose and I know it's common
consensus view here in the GOP if only
we could nominate more of a moderate
candidate they have an almost
uninterrupted track record of losing a
far worse electoral record than the
conservatives you want to win elections
give Americans a choice not an echo now
speaking of polls and statistics
it's a disturbing poll out right now a
poll says that only 18 of young adults
and 29 of Democrats are extremely proud
to be American
not proud in the you know we have a
whole month Pride you know goeth before
destruction and audio spirit before a
fall pride in the sense of patriotism
National loyalty affection for your
country an extension of filial piety
that's disturbing fewer than one in five
young adults
consider themselves to be extremely
proud to be American consider themselves
to be that is patriotic
I'm not as disturbed about a declining
number of Democrats being proud to be
American because
leftism is opposed to patriotism leftism
has always been opposed to patriotism
and so as the Democrats become more
liberal and more left and they follow
their ideas more and more to their
logical conclusion they're going to be
less patriotic that's just built into it
so I'm not surprised by that at all
that's the way it's going to go
young people don't necessarily have to
be less patriotic and yet they are
becoming less patriotic why is that well
I'm in Hungary right now and I can't
help but think of Victor Orban the Prime
Minister here his speech a couple of
days ago
in Romania in which he was lamenting the
fact that Western values these days are
taken to mean nothing more than what was
it LGBT
and mass migration and War going to war
that's it that's what's considered to be
Western values these days not
Christianity not Duty not dignity not
virtue not the pursuit of Truth not
honor or not any of those those are all
they're out
and unfortunately sorry to say
America has been promoting that America
has been flying that rainbow flag
everywhere America with our liberal
establishment has been denying the
things that made America great we've
been denying
the American tradition even you you see
the the new version of Superman Superman
no longer stands for truth justice in
the American way stands for truth
justice and all that other stuff or
truth justice and I don't know diversity
equity and inclusion or something like
that so that's what the libs have been
promoting and so is it any Wonder
that as the country
becomes more and more a stand-in for bad
stuff
that young people will have less and
less affection for their country
Orban made this great point he said
America not America he said Europe is
going to be Christian or it's just going
to fall apart
the only hope to save Europe and I think
we can expand that to the West is
Christianity
or it's going to fall apart or it's
going to descend into a bunch of rival
factions of different appetites and
disordered passions and desires and it's
it's going to turn into Anarchy and
Chaos which is what is happening all
around us
disturbing to see that number reflected
you don't want to hear it but the people
are telling you something they're it's
reflecting a real problem and you're
going to see that number continue to
decline if the country continues to
stand for a bunch of nonsense that
people don't want to be associated with
speaking of that nonsense LGBT
another topic I probably can't cover on
the YouTube show so again you gotta go
to El you got to go to Twitter at mnol
show and you've got to go to daily wire
plus and you've got to go to the RSS
feed and you got to go to Apple podcasts
there are many reasons to oppose
[Music]
Society is not just about you do you and
we'll figure it out later but I'm me and
I'm not going to pay any more taxes
Society is about all of us together
sharing something sharing Norms sharing
a vision of reality and we can't put
truth on the same plane as falsehood and
pretend to be indifferent to them we
can't put good on the same plane as bad
and pretend to be indifferent to the
distinction between the two we've got to
make choices we've got to have a clear
vision and we've got to eradicate these
bad ideas and ideologies from society
when you want to look good
there's one piece of advice I can give
you you got to check out geniusell right
now go to geniusell.com Knowles our
friends of Virginia sell sold out of
their Dark Spot Corrector and our
listeners have been begging begging like
dogs and their knees for a restock well
I've got great news just in time for
summer it is back in stock geniuselle's
famous Dark Spot Corrector has not won
but three Cutting Edge ingredients and
goes to work fast to Target sun spots
dark spots liver spots even old
discoloration on your face and hands you
can now enjoy the Summer sun Beach and
barbecues without embarrassing spots
geniusella's most popular package also
features their summer Essentials like
the best-selling Ultra retinol
moisturizer with a powerful retinol
alternative for safe use in the sun
you'll be amazed at how quickly you see
results or 100 of your money back
guaranteed go to genucel.com Knowles
right now get your dark spot corrector
in the genius all most popular package
geniusell.com Knowles right now save
over seventy seven zero percent off
geniusell's most popular package all
orders will include a mystery luxury
gift while supplies last go to
genucel.com Knowles the greatest
interview show on the internet
many people are talking about it
yes or no it's more than just the most
fun you can have on YouTube
it's also the best way that you can get
to know your favorite stars like Ben
Shapiro where is the Ark of the Covenant
is Satanism protected under the First
Amendment find out Ben's answers in our
episode check out this tease
currently half the country has no
accountability or ability to reason
and it's just a coincidence half of the
people are women
[Music]
ah this is such a this is such a trap
right here again okay all right one two
three
[Music]
man what a tease we are huh the yes or
no game is now back in stock you can go
to daily wire.com shop to get your game
today these games go fast yes or no it's
hands down the best way to delve into
the most thought provoking topics of our
time with family and friends so what are
you waiting for go buy it go to
dailywire.com shop and order yes or no
today
speaking of stuff that I'm Hawking if
you happen to be in Hungary right now
you've got to get this book my book The
Hungarian translation of my blank book
reasons to vote for Democrats in
Hungarian it is of course is
he married to
zulk my utmutato
obviously just rolls off the tongue that
book is available now in Hungarian
bookstores if you're not in Hungary
you're going to have trouble ordering it
you might be able to order it around
Europe you can't get it on Amazon
because Amazon doesn't operate in
Hungary I don't think the Hungarian
bookstores are shipping to the States
but you can check it out anyway just
type in that very easy to write title
I'm very excited I got a copy here my
pal who's with me in Hungary picked up a
copy at the Bookshop today I was glad he
found this copy at the Bookshop it's a
really faithful uh printing of it it
even has my thucydides quote the Epitaph
at the beginning is as alcottas okay I'm
not going to try to do it you get the
you get the point it's in there my whole
bibliography is in there it's a really
faithful reproduction from the publisher
quotes point which is the center for
fundamental rights here I was unable to
get a copy yesterday
shows you a little bit about the
political differences in even in
Budapest
there's some Libs out here I walked into
a Bookshop and I didn't know how to
pronounce it obviously so I pulled up a
picture on my phone of the cover I said
hey do you have this new book it was
just released today this guy looks at me
daggers in his eyes he says we do not
have that book
no I said oh that's too bad yeah I know
it's a new title maybe you don't have it
yet because we are we will not sell that
book
I said okay maybe just I don't know
maybe it's just not making a splash you
hadn't heard of it but then as I'm
walking out he goes that book is blank
pages
I said yeah I know isn't that he wasn't
he wasn't so pleased I think he looked
like a lib
Bookshop owners often are big Libs and
so I was pleased to see it's making a
splash positively and negatively pleased
to see the whole point of this book when
I made it in 2017 amazing we've been
doing this for six years was to irritate
my Democrat friends and relatives and
I'm pleased that it's continuing to
achieve that uh even now overseas even
in Hungary
now speaking of
technology
like the printing press I guess Samantha
not my best transition speaking of
Technology the first artificial
intelligence love song has been created
we've got some of the lyrics here
this is by Lovelace GPT they plugged in
thousands and thousands of love poems
and song lyrics and then they came up
with a song Here Delirious ecstasy
the opening line of which has made some
headlines the line is you're my
biohazard baby
and I thought huh
this is just a kind of a strange lyric
is this just because the the AI was
glitching I don't know I thought you
know with the sexual Revolution with the
widespread hookup culture with swipe
culture
with skyrocketing rates of venereal
disease you're my biohazard baby
probably is inaccurate summation of a
lot of
Modern Love so the AI once again rather
precise here
what does it mean
when we when we plug into Ai and we see
all these weird pictures and poems and
speeches and love songs what is that
does that do anything for us is it just
kind of funny
is it accurate is it not as a totally
off base
you know that I'm skeptical of AI as I
am skeptical of all technology and I do
fear that AI is just getting possessed
by demons sometimes but not all the time
sometimes they're more pedestrian
explanations for things
there's one good thing I'll say about AI
which is that AI
can show you a mirror to yourself and to
your culture because AI is basically
just taking inputs from
this whole big wide web of the internet
and then spitting out uh
an output what whatever whatever that uh
particular type of art will be based on
those inputs and so the idea that forget
about uh biohazard baby the idea that a
modern love song would be Delirious
ecstasy that's true
that's true that is how we think about
love today
we think about love as crazy and
unreasonable and Delirious we think
about it as a kind of an ecstasy you see
this in all of the various sexual
ideologies that are being pushed now
they're being pushed in the name not of
reasonable love and the con and T loss
and the purpose of love and marriage and
family foundation and love and marriage
Love and Marriage go together like a
horse and carriage this I tell you
brother you can't have one without the
other that's gone now we're told
marriage is a joke there's no point to
it there's no point to sex you don't
need to have babies we should just use
contraception all the time if you do
accidentally get pregnant you should
kill the baby through abortion you
should never engage in any kind of
commitment or lifelong Bond through
marriage no no that's all we need to
redefine marriage we need to redefine
all of these things there's no point
other than pleasure there's no point
other than ecstasy in fact
when it comes to one of those sexual
ideologies that we're not allowed to
talk about on YouTube the the great
defense of it from the people who
promote it who have undergrown it
they'll say well I felt a euphoria
after I underwent this procedure or that
I felt a u4 and ecstasy
and this is nothing new exactly in the
old back canals of ancient Greece and
Rome you you see a kind of ecstasy
associated with love in our Christian
civilization for a while we had reigned
that in obviously there was still wacky
stuff going on in the fringes but we had
reigned that in to say no there's
actually a purpose to love and sex and
romance and Affairs and the purpose is
to be married and to stay married and to
have kids and to be fruitful and
multiply and pass on what you believe
your values your beliefs your
institutions your behaviors
your rituals your Traditions all of it
into the Next Generation and as we lose
that
we we lose the Next Generation we lose
the future we're left with nothing but
Delirious irrational ecstasy did I read
too deeply into an AI love song I don't
think I did speaking of stuff going on
in the academy in the universities
not just building AI over there they're
also providing synacures for failed
liberals
the former San Francisco D.A Chase of
Boudin you remember him he's the guy
that allowed San Francisco to just turn
into a complete cesspit of Filth and
excrement and dead druggies and
criminals and it's just you can't even
really travel there anymore so that guy
finally got booted out of office that
was great and now he's making over 200
Grand a year in a position at UC
Berkeley of course
and the Harvard law professor Adrian
vermeul great conservative intellectual
today he pointed out that what this is
is basically a sign a cure for failed
leftists
and it's something the left does very
well and the right is not really good at
it
and it's important it's not just a way
to take care of your buddies it's a way
to encourage further activism because on
the left right now what we are what what
the leftists are told not what we are
told what the leftists are told is hey
go out there be radical push our crazy
policies and I know it might not be
popular but you'll probably be able to
hold on to power and don't worry if you
don't hang on to power
we got your back don't worry you're
never going to miss a meal you're never
going to go broke okay
because if you push it too far we're
gonna we're gonna support that and then
if you do get thrown out of office don't
worry you'll make 200 plus Grand a year
in some post what is he doing at UC
Berkeley
he's going to run the new center that
was just founded the criminal law and
Justice Center at this public university
so your taxpayer dollars at least
California's taxpayer dollars here
and boudin says that the center is going
to give him a better opportunity to
create lasting progress through public
service so the university is going to
pay him 210 Grand a year and they've
said that they're going to fund the
center
four hundred thousand dollars for the
next three years now that number is
important
is that number for a whole Center is
nothing
the university is releasing this as
those we're giving four hundred thousand
dollars to the Cent what are you going
to do with 400 000 you're going to run a
center for three years
you're paying more than half of that in
the salary to the the failed leftist da
heading it
why because the point of hiring him was
not so that you would have someone to
run this important center it's the
opposite you created the center to give
this guy a paycheck the center is
nothing it's not maybe he'll go out and
raise outside money I'm sure he could
he's plugged into pretty wealthy donors
but it doesn't matter the center could
have one office and one chair he doesn't
even need to show up to it it's just a
way to say hey when you fail we got you
so all you other leftists sat there
don't be afraid of trying to radically
implement our agenda the right doesn't
really do that the right does it a
little bit on the neocon squishy liberal
side
I'm not going to name the think tanks
and the institutions I think you know
the ones we're talking about though a
lot of the never Trumper types went over
there when they got booted out of GOP
politics they just go and they collect
their six-figure paycheck and they
publish white papers that nobody reads
and they Lament The Fall of the GOP or
whatever then it doesn't matter
because they in many ways are are just
as much upholders as the liberal
establishment as the radical leftists
like boudinor the difference is that the
role of these squishy conservatives is
to be the court Jesters in the Kingdom
of liberalism so their their role is to
provide a semblance of opposition so it
looks as though there's a real political
fight going on it looks as though
there's a real representation for the
people but there's not
their job is to lose with dignity that's
why they support the candidates who lose
that's not a that's not a flaw of their
system that's the feature of their
system but but in terms of the actual
conservatives
the real they call it I don't know the
populist right or maybe the traditional
right or the conservative writer
whatever the guys who are actually
conservative we don't really have that
if we fail we're kind of in trouble
financially at least and maybe there are
some ways that you can you can parlay
your your work into some other but
it's nothing like the Liberals have it's
and the right needs to build that up
part of how the left has been so
effective at implementing its radical
agenda is it has mitigated the potential
downside for trying to do it
the the conservative right needs to do
the same thing now speaking of the right
and higher education there is one win
one sort of win that we just got
do you remember I bet you do we played
it on the show
Stanford law a while ago
the uh district judge judge Duncan who's
a conservative Trump appointee
he shows up to give a speech and a bunch
of students start howling like banshees
this is at Stanford law supposedly the
number two Law School in the entire
country
they go up and they howl a bunch of
uneducated nonsense at the the federal
judge and so a Dei apparatchik shows up
this administrator of the University
shows up
one would think to restore order and
tell the the ignorant little children to
sit down so that they can listen to
their better the federal judge
doesn't happen the Dei apparatchik shows
up and he starts berating the judge with
the kids and so he starts yelling at the
judge too it's a federal judge a sitting
federal judge who's invited to speak at
supposedly an elite law school so the
good news is that that Dean for
diversity equity and inclusion Tyrion
Steinbach has been fired
she I the way that the email came out is
she was she in the school have parted
ways and she she recognized as the
school did that perhaps she should move
on and she's okay but anyway she's gone
now so this is a win I'm glad that the
bad administrator got fired every other
Dei Dean and vice president and
apparatchik in the entire country should
be fired as well and the whole office
and set of offices should be eliminated
but okay this is a step in the right
direction but notice even the way it was
done
they kind of allow this lady to to keep
her her dignity to keep her
I don't have any of Tyrion I don't know
I don't even remember what this person
looks like but I remember this person
berating the judge and okay it's fine we
parted ways I'm sure that Tyrion
Steinbach will get another job no
problem and the the
I hate to be a glass half empty guy here
because it's good that at least
something happened
but the bigger issue was not
the the leftist apparatchik being a
leftist apparatchee that was the that's
the point that person was was doing her
job
the point is to stir up trouble and to
attack conservatives that's that's the
only thing that Dei counselors exist for
the bigger problem here is that the
students
don't seem ever to have been punished
the students were the one who caused the
trouble the students were the one who
don't deserve a spot at Stanford law
because they they shouldn't have
graduated the seventh grade these are
people who are are do not possess the
Merit academic intellectual Behavioral
or otherwise to be at an elite law
school
these are people who have been promoted
up the ranks because they're
big Libs I guess but but not because
they're going to be good lawyers they're
not I'd be surprised if they can read
the English language
they should have been punished they
should have been expelled from the law
school
they weren't no big deal okay that
that Dei counselor was a little too on
the nose Okay that was a little too
public he had a little bit of bad PR
maybe the donors weren't so happy with
that so okay naughty naughty okay we're
gonna let you leave now but we're not
going to change anything
why because ultimately these radicals
are are doing the bidding
of the broader liberal establishment
ultimately even in in moments that seem
Anarchist downright anarchist
Lawless well that creates the
opportunity
for the liberal establishment to come in
and seize more power and wield more
power and make more rules that was the
George Floyd riots
George Floyd writes yeah they burn down
some buildings yeah they attack even
some places that Libs like but it's okay
the Anarchy
will create the opportunity to further
the liberal agenda as we've seen
now you might have been one of the tens
of millions of people who watch
Netflix's hit you on making a murderer
if so then you're gonna love daily wire
plus new exclusive tempered docu-series
with Candace Owens convicting a murderer
coming this summer whether it's
explosing the explosion whether it is
exposing black lives matter or all the
craziness around the covid healthcare
industry Candace Owens has never been
afraid to challenge The Narrative she
will find the truth wherever it leads
when Candace found out that some facts
might have been omitted in Netflix a
series she set out to uncover the real
story behind the Stephen Avery case the
end result is convicting a murder you
don't want to miss it you'll also get
all sorts of other content on daily wire
plus including greatest live ever sold
what is a woman largest collection of
content from Dr Jordan B Peterson right
now go to daily wire.com subscribe
become a member see the truth when it
finally comes out
some halfway okay kind of good news out
of Stanford unfortunately the military
Academy's not so lucky
the Air Force Academy superintendent
is supporting a scholarship for students
who are demi-gender
maybe we get to keep this one on YouTube
I don't know because I don't know what
demigender is
and neither does the Air Force Academy
superintendent as representative Matt
Gates proved in this Exchange
you just said that your answer on why we
why we do such this this full hug of
these diversity Concepts is because it's
all about the fighting force that we
draw from but you're literally pushing a
program in the academies that says if
you're a cisgender woman
woman a non-binary agender by gender
two-spirit Demi gender what's Demi
gender
sir that's a uh that's a a term of the
people that are eligible for that
particular scholarship that is available
to it's a person who looks at their
gender in a in a different uh a
different way than I do sir well sure
that's all of these people you're a
cisgender man you don't even get to
apply well do you know what demigender
really means
I'm not really sure sir right so do you
know what agender means
all one word not a space gender but
agender
uh sir I don't I Gotta Give the Air
Force guy credit here
at least he admitted right outright he
says I I don't know
I don't huh what is I don't know what
Debbie a gender this that or the other I
don't know if I don't know what it is I
know I support it but I have no idea
what it is
you know what it represents that what I
I don't know what Demi gender is but
whatever it is what it represents is
that the US military is prioritizing
sexual deviance over Fitness
prioritizing all sorts of leftist lib
woke priorities over Fitness we know
that our publicist server at Media
Matters it got very excited yesterday
and publicized this clip in which I said
that forget about the Demi
whatever stuff
the fact that we have women fighting in
combat is a stain and a disrace on our
nation and it is
it is
it is a bad kind of thing for a nation
to send out its women to be blown up by
jihadis that's bad
I'm sure there are women willing to do
it I'm sure they've got a ton of courage
and are willing to sacrifice all sorts
of things for the country
but that's not what the military is
about
that's that's an important constitutive
part of serving in the military but what
the military is for is not proving that
anybody can do anything and that's not
what it's for it's not for social
experimentation it's not for social
engineering it's not it's for killing
the bad guys
and it's for
representing our country and the best of
our country
and the best ideals of our country
and one of those ideals is that we're
going to protect women we're not going
to send them to get blown up
says nothing about
the courage of these women and take it
even further
the the pan gender I I have no doubt
that there are people who are confused
about their sex who
are willing to serve their country who
have served their country have served
their country honorably who have
demonstrated all sorts of Courage I'm
grateful for their service that's
wonderful
that's not what the military is for the
military is not for proving those things
to individuals
we're just putting the cart before the
horse get here when Joe Biden decides
not to pick the top recommendation of
his military advisors to lead the Navy
but to pick a lady because she's a lady
that's a pro that's called putting the
cart before the horse
that's called prioritizing things over
the cheap purpose of our military and in
the case of our military that can be a
real life or death
question
it's the top brass and it's discouraging
getting back to that poll we talked
about earlier when young people are
saying I'm not really proud of my
country at all why is that
it's not because of ordinary Americans
ordinary Americans generally speaking
still have a lot of common sense
it's not we're talking about the
military it's not because of ordinary
servicemen in the military they still
have way more common sense than the
average civilian
but the ruling class the political
leaders including the political leaders
at the Pentagon
the ones like Mark milley Who start
whining and crying about white rage and
say well I just want to make sure that
my troops understand that the origins of
white rage including the people running
Nasa say the purpose of NASA is to
appease the Muslim world what what are
you talking about including all of these
political leaders who put the cart
before the horse
that that is why people are down on
their country and I get it I totally get
why they are
speaking of Fitness this is a story
wanted to get to for a few days now it
comes from the college fix
University in Scotland
has decided to put a trigger warning on
a classic book
that's nothing new shouldn't make the
headlines
do a trigger warning on Huckleberry Finn
this book talks about race
trigger warning uh yeah okay we all know
that
this one took it a little further
there's a trigger warning on Ernest
Hemingway's old man in the sea
because the book involves quote
graphic fishing scenes
I was going to try to get through with a
straight face and I failed at doing that
the novel contains graphic fishing
scenes and so the university has this
new content warning to quote enable
students to make informed choices
a nation
that can't handle fishing a civilization
that can't handle the brutal reality of
fishing
is not a civilization that is going to
survive
we're not talking about killing the
enemy this is good old Georgie Patton
remember the speech to the third Army
what are You Soldiers gonna do you're
gonna go kill the enemy you're gonna
have the blood and guts of your best
friend beside you flying on your face
and what are you gonna do charge forward
not like those yellow piss four enemies
out there that we're gonna gut
like soldiers we're gonna run through
them like a hot knife through butter
that was a that was General Patton now
we've gone to
would it be all right if I talk to you
about fishing
it's not a serious
it's not a serious country or organ or
or civilization
when you see that 18 number and now
proud of my country I know it's in
Scotland we're talking about the West
broadly here
then we're at a place where you
understand okay there's finally some
consequences to a civilization declining
itself those same students who can't
bear the thought of a guppy getting a
hook through his mouth
I promise you those students are
perfectly fine snuffing out the life of
a human baby in the womb I promise you
that
I promise you those people they don't
care 60 million babies have been killed
in the United States since Roe v Wade oh
that's fine that's wonderful they're
going to march in defense of that
the nice way to read the the content
warning on graphic fishing scenes is
that we're getting we're becoming gentle
or a Kindler gentler Nation as a
moderate Centrist squishy Republican
type once said
that's one that's a little too
charitable we're not becoming gentler
we're becoming a lot cooler and we're
becoming a lot cooler in virtually all
areas of our public policy and we're
doing it with a little smile on our face
and we're doing it with the the
saccharin slogans of some Dei counselor
who's not only perfectly willing to kill
innocent human life but who's perfectly
willing to kill a civilization
got to reorder those priorities folks or
the numbers in all areas are going to
continue to drop no member block this
week because I'm in Hungary and I'm
going to be speaking in Hungary and
Hungary keeps showing up in the news in
this major civilizational battle and I'm
very excited that I will get to
contribute to that in some small way on
Friday when I speak at the MCC Fest
Matthias corvinus collegium a speech not
to be missed I hope
little letter to the world I consider
all my speeches letters to the world but
this one's more so because I'm all
around the world for this one so make
sure you tune in then make sure you get
the book meets
mutato
I'm Michael Knowles see you tomorrow
[Music]
thank you